Speaker 1: The MAGA love affair with Elon
Musk seems to be coming to a sort of predictable
end.
This all sort of got going around the Twitter
purchase that was simply not to be.
Elon Musk of Tesla and SpaceX fame announced
that he wanted to buy Twitter and that he
had reached a deal with Twitter.
I didn't believe it for a second.
I didn't think he was going to buy Twitter.
Then it sort of like nothing moves forward
for a little bit.
And Elon Musk announced that he's having some
concerns about the number of bots on the platform.
This was after a whole flood of right wing
users came back to Twitter following right
wing accounts.
On the heels of Elon Musk's announcement,
Musk started to say, Well, I'm not really
getting the data I want about the number of
fake users and bots.
So I'm putting the purchase on hold.
And I said at that point he was never going
to buy Twitter and he's not going to buy Twitter.
And now Elon Musk actually says that he's
backing out.
And it's, of course, not at all surprising.
But in addition to this, Donald Trump and
Elon Musk are now publicly feuding in the
sense that Trump appears to be lying again
and Elon Musk seems to be telling the truth.
Now, I think a lot of this was inevitable
in the sense that Elon Musk is basically a
self-centered opportunist, as are many tech
CEOs.
I don't necessarily say that pejoratively,
although it could certainly be interpreted
as such.
And as a result, he and Donald Trump are now
not getting along well.
During his rally at a in Anchorage, Alaska,
Donald Trump said the or actually, you know,
that's the wrong order.
First and foremost.
Donald Trump at his Anchorage rally said,
Elon Musk told me that he voted for me.
But later said, I've never voted for a Republican.
And so therefore he must be a liar.
Elon Musk responded to a report of that on
Twitter by saying It's not true, meaning it's
not true.
I ever told Trump I voted for him.
So Trump getting called out for one apparent
lie.
Then at the Anchorage rally, Trump going on
a rampage attacking Elon Musk, who he also
referred to as Leon Musk during the rally.
Speaker 2: Another one of our highest priorities
under a Republican Congress will be to stop
left wing censorship and to restore free speech
in America.
And go out, by the way, while I'm here and
sign up now for Truth Social.
It's hot as a pistol and you see that?
I call that one, right, Leon?
I tell you what, Ellen.
Ellen is not going to buy Twitter.
Now, where did you hear that before?
From me.
From a fake account.
She says a lot of them.
Now he's got himself a mess.
You know, he said the other day, Oh, I've
never voted for a Republican.
I said, I didn't know that.
He told me voted for me.
So he's another Bush, I guess, but he's not
going to be by and not going to be buying
it, although he might later.
Who the hell knows what's going to happen?
He's got a pretty rotten contract.
I looked at his contract.
Not a good contract.
Right.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So Breitbart highlighting that clip.
And then Elon Musk responded, I don't hate
the man, but it's time for Trump to hang up
his hat and sail into the sunset.
Democrats should also call off the attack.
Don't make it so that Trump's only way to
survive is to regain the presidency.
So the love affair between the MAGA people
and Elon Musk, predictably, predictably sunsetting.
I think we could say.
Now, let's talk a little bit about Elon Musk.
I get a lot of people in my audience who are
Elon Musk fanboys.
They love him.
They love his products.
They love everything.
And then I hear from people who absolutely
hate Elon Musk and they see him as some right
wing extremist and all these different things.
I well, it might not surprise you that much,
the same way that I don't really care about
or fall into the cult of personality among
politicians.
I you know, I was a Bernie supporter.
I wasn't part of the Bernie cult, so to speak.
There's the Tulsi cult.
Andrew Yang had a cult around him.
Donald Trump is I just see these as people.
Hopefully they do more good than harm.
And if I think that they're the best option,
vote for them.
But beyond that, I don't really get too sucked
into the personalities of it.
And also in having met a lot of these people,
they're just normal people.
I mean, think about all the flaws.
Everyone you personally know has they're just
normal people because they're normal people.
All of these other people are as well.
And much the same way on a business level.
If you bet against Elon Musk, it doesn't seem
to be the best bet.
Elon Musk has had a number of really successful
businesses I've disclosed.
I bet on that when in 2015 I bought Tesla
stock and the stock went crazy, although now
it's down from its peak and whatever.
It seemed that that was going to be a business
that would grow.
And it's by far the largest electric vehicle
manufacturer now in the United States.
Great.
The degree to which Tesla has advanced the
electric vehicle development and normalization
is incredible.
And the reason that every other vehicle manufacturer
now is scrambling to get more electric vehicles
out there is because of the success of Tesla.
That's a great thing.
Elon Musk also is just wacky on a lot of political
stuff.
The recent tweets about the the right is where
it's always been, but the left has become
extreme.
That's just wrong as wacky.
I don't know who gave him that idea.
Just wrong.
His recent thing about I'm now going to vote
for Republicans.
I'm only voting for Republicans.
Republicans are better for this, that or the
other reason.
He's just wrong.
It's wacky.
It's completely wacky.
Disagree with it completely.
But at its core, the interpretation that makes
the most sense to me is Elon Musk has some
bad ideas and some good ideas.
He uses tax law to his advantage as all of
these rich guys do.
He is a self-centered opportunist who at the
end of the day, wants what's best for himself
and for his companies.
It's not a big surprise.
We don't have to deify or demonize and just
recognize it for what it is.
And all of that being said, he has never struck
me as a particularly reactionary guy.
I think he's gotten sucked into right wing
Republican politics.
Maybe it's hanging around with Rogan.
I don't know what it is, but it seemed as
though the love affair between the MAGA people
and Elon Musk was destined to end, and it
seems that it is indeed now ending, so hopefully
we can close the chapter on that.
I don't believe he ever intended to buy Twitter
and I don't think he's ever going
to buy it.